nearly 600,000 people have seen this
remarkable video of a human pushing
himself to the limit yes this is Tommy
Carroll and despite being blind since
the age of two he can do this
to see somebody doing something has
difficult physically as skateboarding me
and he's just flawlessly doing it by
using a totally different sensory input
it's it's really really humbling to see
I think Tommy is an exceptional human
being he was born with retinal blastoma
which prevented him from seeing the
world and he has overcome this by using
his hearing how does Tommy use sound to
skate Tommy is actually using a form of
echolocation to be able to skate in this
way he's sending out sounds that would
be the sounds from the wheels on his
skateboard and he's analyzing the sounds
that come back to him using sound in
this way allows Tommy to form a mental
map of the part many of us can do this
we're just not really aware of it think
about what it sounds like when you fill
up a glass with water you know without
looking when it's getting close to the
top and this is the kind of sensation
that Tommy has been able to manipulate
to a great extent much greater than then
somebody with sight would be able to do
so Tommy's using echolocation to
determine his position by the sound of
the skateboard how else can this
technique be used
Tommy's actually not unique in his
ability to use echolocation to
essentially see his environment other
people who've lost their sight
will make clicks they don't have
skateboard wheels so they all audibly
make clicks in order to help them
navigate their environments brain scans
of people that are actively using this
kind of echolocation technique show that
the area of the brain that is being
utilized at this time is the visual
cortex this is the same area that
sighted people use to put images
together so people who have lost their
sight have the ability to use their
visual cortex to interpret sound because
of this I guess it's fair to say that
Tommy is actually seeing with sound